a Time magazine journalist reveals the
true motivation behind a OCS rise
democrats revealed their a brutally
anti-israel streak and we check the
mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show what a long and yet
beneficial week i mean to it so this has
been a long but great week if you
haven't picked up a copy of my book the
right side of history yet go do it now
it is number one on amazon it is number
one in nonfiction on Barnes & Noble so
thank you all if you've already picked
up a copy of the book I'm very proud of
it I think that it's a I think it's a
real useful work and I think it'll be
useful for you and your kids and people
that you know so help us keep it number
one maybe well not maybe we'll knock on
the door to the the top of the Times the
New York Times list that list by the way
is a joke I can discuss that a little
bit later before we do any of that first
let me remind you you need better
underwear when men and women upgrade
from their shabby outdated multipack
underwear to Tommy John the most
comfortable on the planet they've got a
lot to say about it like John his only
regret is that he didn't try Tommy John
earlier or Julia who says that Tommy
John is so comfortable she forgets she's
wearing them the point is men and women
all across America are crazy about Tommy
John both Tommy John men and women's
underwear sport a no wedgie guarantee
would help me in high school
comfortable stay put waist bands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft and designed to move with you not
against you Plus Tommy John has dress
shirts and undershirts that always stay
tucked ridiculously soft loungewear and
go anywhere apparel that is versatile
enough to go from boardroom to boxing
class for ladies check out their new
Tommy John era collection Tommy John is
so sure you're gonna love the fit and
feel it's all back Brad their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
that means if you don't love that first
pair you'll get a full refund Tommy John
no adjustment needed hurry over to Tommy
John comm / Ben right now get 20% off
your first order that is Tommy John comm
/ Ben for 20% off again Tommy John comm
/ Ben how do I know that these come
underwear comfortable because they're on
my tuchus right at this very instant
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off your
first order alright so a lot to get to
here expectation is but the mobile
report could drop as early as today
according to NBC News President Trump on
Friday continued to claim there was no
collusion between his 2016 presidential
campaign and Russia as Washington braces
for special counsel Robert Muller's
highly
report Trump said he has no idea when
the report is going to drop he said drop
he says its how the big hugs and here's
the reality in all likelihood this
report is not going to contain anything
that Democrats can run on he added that
the AG the Attorney General William bar
will ultimately make a decision about
the reports release Muller is supposed
to submit the report to bar at the
conclusion of his investigation into the
Russian election interference and Trump
bar is required to notify Congress about
Muller's findings however Justice
Department regulations do not require
Barty of a comprehensive report to
lawmakers in fact the report is expected
not to be comprehensive
it is expected not to include all sorts
of unverified allegations because of
current Justice Department regulations
unlike the Starr investigation the
Justice Department regulations now
govern what comes out from the Muller
report apparently they're reporting no
more indictments are expected is
according to ABC News Jonathan Karl
reporting there is no shortage of
speculation on the special counsel
Robert Miller's report much of it
totally uninformed but we don't need to
speculate on the scope the man who
appointed Muller has already given us a
potential roadmap on what to expect from
it the special counsel the bottom line
do not expect a harsh condemnation of
President Trump or any of his associates
if they have not been charged with
crimes why because it turns out the
prosecutors aren't supposed to just
spill their guts into the public unless
they are charging you with a crime it is
not their responsibility to inform the
public about all of the other various
and sundry matters in which you may have
been involved the roadmap comes in the
form of a little notice to 12-page
letter written by deputy AG rod
Rosenstein last june the much-maligned
deputy AG rod Rosenstein Trump dislikes
him the letter was written to Senate
Judiciary Chairman Chuck Grassley the
letter was in response to Grassley's
demands for more information on the
Special Counsel investigation and it
offers a brief history of special
counsel investigations it actually
quotes former and future AG William Barr
who appointed three special counsels
during his time as AG under President
George HW Bush in the letter Rosenstein
makes it clear he believes the DOJ will
not and cannot without violating
long-standing Department of Justice
policy included disparaging or
incriminating information about anybody
who has not been charged with a crime so
don't expect this thing to be a 500-page
Ken
star compendium of details about Donald
Trump's private life Rosenstein wrote
punishing wrongdoers through judicial
proceedings is only one part of the
department's mission we also have a duty
to prevent the disclosure of information
that would unfairly tarnished people who
are not charged with crimes sources
familiar with the investigation believed
there are no more indictments coming
from the Special Counsel a Mika
Brzezinski was reading this story on air
this morning on Morning Joe and you
could see her face collapse I mean she
was really upset about this that there
are no more indictments expected from
the Special Counsel if that's all that
Muller has got this thing has been a
giant waste of time legitimately like if
all he came up with is a bunch of people
who lied to the FBI about ancillary
matters going to jail for a bunch of
random stuff for very short periods of
time for the most part if all they came
out of this was that they nailed Paul
Manafort for being a violator of the
Foreign Registration Act the foreign
lobbyists Registration Act and all they
got out of this was Michael Cohen and
tax human aliens my goodness what a
waste of America's time and money
Rosenstein is emphatic on this point he
says in fact disclosing uncharged
allegations against American citizens
without a law enforcement need is
considered to be a violation of a
prosecutors trust which of course makes
sense what you don't want is people
being tried in the court of public
opinion based on information that wasn't
strong enough to prosecute in the first
place later in the letter Rosenstein
says he makes this standard clear to
anyone under investigation even public
officials he says no matter who an
investigation involves an ordinary
citizen a local or state politician a
campaign official a foreign agent an
officer of the federal legislative
executive or judicial branch agents and
prosecutors are obligated to protect its
confidentiality now I know there are a
lot of people who are on the Left
listening to this and they're thinking
wait a second didn't James Comey come
out about Hillary Clinton and give a
full explanation of their entire
investigation before recommending that
she not be indicted the answer is yes
and that's why James Comey should have
been fired at the time when James Comey
came forward and exonerated Hillary
Clinton on charges for which she should
have been indicted he should have either
shut up and said no indictment necessary
or he should have come forward and
indicted he split the baby and it ended
up costing Hillary Clinton the
presidency at least quite plausibly in
this letter from last year
seems rectly takes issue with the
justification then FBI director James
Comey used to publicly criticize Hillary
Clinton in 2016
even as he decided not to charge her
with a crime at the time Comey justified
the break with longtime DOJ practice as
an extraordinary step necessary because
of circumstances so unusual they were
comparable to a 500 year flood
that's because Comey was an idiot and
terrible at his job Rosenstein wrote it
is important for the DOJ to follow
established procedures especially when
the stakes are high Rosenstein is
correct James Comey by the way the
reason he did that is because he knew
that Hillary Clinton probably should
have been indicted but as testimony now
from Lisa Paige and Peter struck has
established the Obama DOJ crammed down
on the FBI that she would not be
indicted and thus James Comey decided to
take it on his own shoulders the hit he
decided that to preserve the reputation
of both the FBI and DOJ he would come
clean with the American public he did a
deep to service to both Hillary Clinton
and the general public in doing what he
did he should have been fired forthwith
but the fact is that the Obama
administration wanted him to do that
because they figured that it would end
up getting Hillary Clinton off the hook
not costing her the presidency of course
they ended up figuring wrong so if the
Mullah report drops today obviously all
the presses will stop it will be the big
deal we will see what is in this thing
presumably pretty quickly because you
assume there's not gonna be a long
turnaround time between Muller releasing
the report and William Barr condensing
that report and releasing it to Congress
in which case it'll be leaked to the
public in relatively short order but
this is good for President Trump this
timeline is good for president Trump
assuming there's no deeply damning
material in the report and there is one
exception it is possible that Muller if
he thinks these offenses are impeachable
but not criminal could in fact include a
lot of detail in this report simply to
justify his time expenditure on this
thing but if it ends up that there's not
much here and we are getting rid of this
in March of 2019 not in November of 2020
that is very good news for president
Trump he can then move on and we won't
have to hear a president Trump fulminate
except that he will rightly say that he
is going to be continued to be targeted
by the Democratic House for a bunch of
investigations that the Moller
investigation has already concluded are
unnecessary
but that is where this is moving if it
turns out that the molar indictments are
a big nothing there are no more
indictments
if the mullah report is essentially an
empty bag and Democrats continue to
launch investigations into matters
already covered by Muller Trump is
always going to be able to say listen he
said I didn't obstruct justice he said I
didn't collude with Russia and now
you're coming after me for the same
exact crap simply to smear me obviously
this is politically motivated there is
no real serious allegation that I
impeded the Muller investigation at any
step along the way see this is the thing
all the folks on the Left who keep
claiming the Trump obstructed justice
there is no actual evidence of Trump
obstructing justice
he sweeted a few times at people like
Michael Cohen that is the closest you
can come to an argument that he
obstructed justice it is not like when
Bill Clinton legitimately
told people to lie to the FBI for him
like directly told people to do this
according to the Star report and
according to testimony from those people
that's what Bill Clinton was caught up
on there is nothing like that in the
Trump case at least so far as I can
remember or see and we've been through a
lot of this material what that means is
that if the Democrats continue to press
on this score they're going to be seen
as vindictive they're going to be seen
as petty and they could get caught up in
this thing for the next two years as a
sort of fanservice it's funny sometimes
you watch movies and the movies have
plot lines that make no sense kind of
ancillary plot lines that make no sense
you're like why don't you just stick to
the main plot line and then you'll hear
inevitably oh this was fanservice
this is particularly true in comic book
movies there's some sort of plot line
that nobody cares about and like why is
this here
oh because it was in the comics and
there's a small group of fans who
desperately wanted to see this character
from the comics it's fanservice the
Democratic Party has to decide whether
it wants to be a fanservice party or
whether it wants to win the 2020
election it can't have both if the
Democrats decide to be a fanservice
party then spend all of their time
launching foolish investigations into
President Trump Trump is rightly gonna
be able to say you guys are wasting your
time and my money and everybody's money
on your dumb investigations instead of
focusing in on the issues at hand and
then his fulmination will actually have
some teeth to it him fulminating against
miller never made any sense Mulla works
for the executive branch him fulminating
against jeff sessions the AG didn't make
any sense either jeff sessions worked
for him
was selected by him rod Rosenstein works
for president Trump they're all in the
executive branch but Trump fulminating a
congress that is a that is a tried
tested and true strategy for winning
reelection this has been true ever since
Harry Truman won re-election in 1948 on
the back of arguing that he had to deal
with the do-nothing Republican Congress
and he pulled his chestnuts out of the
fire against Thomas Dewey this has been
a long-standing historical running
strategy by President President Obama by
the way did the same thing in 2012 he
said we were going great guns until 2010
and now we're being obstructed and I'm
running against a do-nothing useless
Congress and then he won re-election
Trump can do the same thing now so in a
certain way it could be a blessing in
disguise if Democrats decide to
investigate him up the wazoo yeah it'll
be a pain in the butt yeah it's bad for
all the people who work for president
Trump we're gonna have to wire up and
spend a lot of money to defend
themselves against dumb investigations
but it does give Trump something to run
on that is not the Democrats calling him
an applause ekend we will discuss an
amazing time magazine cover piece about
aoc first let's talk about how you can
make your back and neck and feel better
I want to talk about teeter inversion
table it may sound weird hanging upside
down is actually a great way to
decompress the back and joints after a
workout and boost recovery so you might
not think it but I do work out a lot
underneath this blazer why is the body
of a Greek god but along with those
workouts come a bit of back stress and
that is why I use the teeter inversion
table is called inversion therapy it
uses gravity and your own body weight to
decompress the spine and release tension
in your shoulders neck and joints
inverting after your workout boosts the
recovery process by stretching and
elongating your spine and joints
rehydrating the discs and relaxing tired
muscles decompressing on a teeter
inversion table for just a few minutes a
day is a great addition to your daily
routine to maintain a healthy back and
joins I love this thing it is the better
teeter it is the best inversion table on
the market over three million people
have put their trust in teeter they've
been the best known name and inversion
tables since 1981 they're offering a
great deal just for my listeners right
now for a limited time you can get the
brand-new 2019 teeter Fit spine
inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym and with
this deal you'll get 150 bucks off when
you go to teeter calm / bend you also
get free shipping for your return 60-day
money
guarantee there's no risk to you go
check it out right now Teeter comm slash
man that is te e ter comm slash Ben and
get that new 2019 Teeter Fit spine
inversion table plus a free pair of
gravity boots all of that with 150 bucks
off when you go to Teeter comm slash man
go check them out right now make it back
feel better today okay so as I say the
Democrats are in a bit of trouble if
they have staked all of their all of
their claim to the presidency on the
back of Trump colluded with Russia and
they boxed themselves in here they
couldn't accept the fact that Trump won
the election in the same way that stacey
abrams in georgia refuses to accept that
she lost her election for governor of
georgia and now the democrats are trying
to elevate her this this seems like a a
failed strategy he used to be in
American politics that if you lost you
went away the idea was that if you lost
you went away and we didn't really want
to hear from you because we had rejected
you and if you wanted to run again later
in some other lane you did that right
Mitt Romney no one wanted to hear from
Mitt Romney after he lost in 2012 there
wasn't a lot of talk about voter fraud
or Mitt Romney being being job to out of
out of being the president of the United
States he sort of went away and then the
Republican Party moved on and then he
ran for Senate in Utah anyone and now we
care what he thinks again but until then
not too much
John Kerry after he lost in 2004 went
away Al Gore after he lost in 2000 went
away now Democrats after they lose say
that they didn't lose and then not only
don't they go away they rip on the
institutions of American government and
suggest that because they didn't really
lose the other person in office is
illegitimate if that's your best shot at
president I just I literally do not
understand the strategy I legitimately
don't understand that strategy it's not
like President Trump doesn't provide
them fodder to run on every day but if
they are fully invested in the narrative
that Hillary Clinton is the actual
president of the United States and thus
the best attack on president Trump is
that he is illegitimate that sort of
stuff does not carry weight with the
American public for whom President Trump
has been the legitimate president since
his election in 2016
again that doesn't mean Democrats aren't
going to show up they will they don't
like President Trump but if your best
shot at Trump is Russian collusion after
all of this man what a disappointment
you're going to be to the vast majority
of Americans in the upcoming election
cycle okay meanwhile the true star of
the demo
party so fresh so incredibly fresh and
so incredibly faced Alexandria Ocasio
Cortese wow she is so fresh and so face
she's on the cover of Time magazine
today now we here at the ben shapiro
show are obviously obsessed with her
because we talk about her when she's on
the cover of Time magazine
just like we talk about other
politicians when they're on the cover of
Time magazine and just like we cover
politicians when Tom Perez calls them
the new fresh face of the Democratic
Party but there is an amazing piece by a
woman named Charlotte alter over at Time
magazine and the piece is a window into
the utter ingratitude of an entire
generation of people in the United
States and think about people my age
around my age and younger AOC is only
about five years younger than I am so
Charlotte alter says changes closer than
we think inside a OCS unlikely rise her
piece says every ten minutes or so
someone knocks on the big wooden door of
a Ozzy's office on Capitol Hill the
noise makes staffers stiffen it's almost
always a harmless fan one of dozens who
arrive each day leading neon-colored
post-it notes his devotional offerings
but in her first three months in
Congress aides say enough people have
threatened to murder Ocasio Cortez the
Capitol Police trained her staff to
perform risk assessments of her visitors
this is the daily reality for America's
newest human Rorschach test
Wonder Woman of the left Wicked Witch of
the right Ocasio Cortez has become the
second most talked-about politician in
America after the President of the
United States that's not actually true
if you look at the number of Google
mentions of AOC she does follow Joe
Biden she follows she follows bethe
O'Rourke she follows Bernie Sanders she
follows Nancy Pelosi in many cases but
never mind
she's very fresh and very face now
here's what I love about this the entire
article is about how a OSI has lived a
suffering life the entire article is
about how a OSE understands the plight
of young people who are truly suffering
in today's America and yet it contains
at this line at the same time she's a
freshman legislator trying to get the
hang of her first a big full-time job
she's 29 years old this is her first big
full-time job in Congress that does not
sound like a life of hardship in the
United States going to Boston University
being given a degree for learning
apparently nothing working at various
odd jobs while your parents are
upper-middle income and your first big
time job is in Congress that doesn't
sound like a rags to riches story that
sounds like a some riches to more riches
story and yet she is a suffering servant
she's a suffering servant according to
Charlotte alter I miss being able to go
outside in sweats she says in her office
one day in March settling into a black
leather chair after a long day of
subcommittee hearings
she's much smaller than she looks on TV
with a warm but cautious manner God the
hagiography I can't go anywhere in
public and just be a person without a
lot of people watching everything I do
oh poor you welcome to the club and come
on who cares
Oh AOC represents one vision of the
Democratic Party's future she's a young
Hispanic woman three cornerstones of the
party's electoral coalition she's a
Democratic Socialist at a time when
confidence in capitalism is declining
especially among progressive Millennials
and then this this article just goes on
to talk about how wonderful she is in
every aspect she's wonderful and caring
and decent and terrific I love this on
Ocasio Cortez's office bookshelf near a
picture of her late father and a photo
of her with a local Girl Scout Troop two
books nestled together an uneasy union
one is the Federalist Papers written
mostly by James Madison and Alexander
Hamilton and published in 1788 the other
is the uninhabitable earth life after
warming warming written by journalist
David Wallace wells 231 years later
there's a picture of Wonder Woman
leaning in one corner of the office and
a giant cardboard cutout of car D B's
face and another oh wow she's just she's
unbelievable she's amazing now here is
where things become hilarious
they say she was born into a
working-class family in the Park Chester
section of the Bronx yeah her family
moved out of there real fast into a
pretty upper income area of New York as
Michael Mills of The Daily wire has
pointed out he grew up in the
neighboring County which was not quite
as wealthy her dad owned a small
architecture company her Puerto Rico
born mother cleaned houses they were
deeply rooted in the neighborhood but
also wary of its limitations Ocasio
Cortez has told friends she learned
early on that wearing hoop earrings and
the name plate necklaces was fine in the
Bronx but she wouldn't be taken
seriously if she wore them to a job
interview the family moved to the
prosperous westchester county suburb of
Yorktown Heights when she was about five
five so the first part of that paragraph
makes it sound as though she lived her
entire life growing up in the Bronx and
then she moved into the upper echelons
of American society her family moved
into a nice area when she was five five
she got she describes herself as a dorky
kid who once asked for a microscope for
her birthday her 2007 high school
microbiology project on the effect of
antioxidants on the lifespan of
roundworms
won second place in the microbiology
category at the Intel International
Science and Engineering Fair she often
joined her mom to clean the homes of
neighbors and she wrote her college
application essay about two of them
helping a man who lost the wife the only
way they could by cleaning out his
fridge she took out student loans to
enroll at BU Wow I mean unlike everyone
else she's got loans to go to college
Wow she really must have been hard up
graduating in 2011 with a degree in
economics and international relations by
the way she knows nothing about either
of those two things that shows you how
crappy our colleges are now the part of
this that is really going is not that
Time magazine put her on its cover the
media have been pushing her since she
defeated Joe Crowley with like 15,000
votes in a deep-blue area in a plurality
in a plurality Hispanic congressional
district it people treat this as though
it's a massive shocker it was only a
massive shocker if you weren't following
the race all that closely is sort of the
truth but regardless you don't want to
miniature accomplishment she won 15,000
votes in a heavily blue suburb that was
majority or plurality Hispanic against a
white guy who was not super popular and
didn't spend a lot of time in his home
districts reportedly in any case
regardless she won but she was
immediately elevated to the upper
echelons of democratic leadership and
the real reason is because she's
attractive and she looks like she's
having a good time and she and she's
kind of fun and she knows how to use
Instagram and she and she has an instant
pot and all the rest of this but
Charlotte alter the the columnist of
Time is what I actually want to talk
about not AOC because she spilled the
beans and why it is that Millennials
think like AOC and it is pretty
astonishing it is pretty astonishing and
pretty damning if you're a millennial
and you think like a OC because you
think like Charlotte altar you need to
get your head straight now because
you are not being accurate about the
state of the world I'll explain in just
one second first let's talk about how
you keep your home safer rings mission
is to make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor they'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on ranked devices I have a ring
device on my front door that means if
somebody rings the doorbell and you know
they may not be somebody who I'm
interested in letting into my house I
can let them know that from 3,000 miles
away and they don't know that I'm not
home ring is fantastic for monitoring
what's going on at your at your property
at your house where at your apartment as
a listener you now have a special offer
on a ring starter kit available right
now there's a video doorbell and a
motion-activated floodlight cam and the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home just go to ring.com slash Bend
that is ring.com slash man if you are
concerned about your home security and
let me tell you if you live in big
cities like Los Angeles if you live in a
big city anywhere around the country you
got to be worried about your safety on
your property simply because the
governing coalition's have done such a
poor job of keeping big cities safe from
property crime these days go to ring.com
slash men go check them out ring calm
slash Ben right now and they have a
special offer on the ring starter kit
available so you're gonna get some money
off go check them out ring Tom / Ben
okay so the real story here is not a Oh
see the real story is the columnist who
wrote about her Charlotte alter so
Charlotte alter has been appearing on
all the major media to talk up her big
news story about AOC yeah she's the best
so Charlotte alter suggested that AO
sees dominance is inevitable inevitable
this is what she suggested her ascent is
inevitable and honestly it is in some
ways and the thing about AOC and the
reason that she is I think tapping into
something that is so exciting to some
and threatening to others is that she is
really bringing us into the politics of
the 21st century she is a 21st century
leader trying to tackle 21st century
problems in a body that is largely
dominated by 20th century thinking okay
what the hell is she even talking about
that makes no sense why is this person
columnist why is this person in our
Porsche closer self a journalist for
Time magazine just writing these
drooling pieces about ALS a and then she
says the reason that people are upset at
AOC is because they're just jealous it's
not that AOC is completely ignorant and
says dumb things and gets massive media
attention it's just pure jealousy pure
jealousy weird because I don't really
feel jealous of her as much as I feel
angry at the media for having decided
that her ideas are worth airing and
defending despite the fact that they are
unintelligible masses of gibberish here
at Charlotte altar playing defense as a
journalist for AOC again she's a
journalist folks don't worry the media
are not biased in any way there are
certainly some Democrats who are a
little annoyed that she's getting so
much airspace and so many headlines and
they think that you and they you know
frankly I think seem a little jealous
that she's getting so much attention
they would like to be on the cover of
Time magazine but everyone that we spoke
to who's worked with her has said that
she's kind she's prepared
she you know she shows up she does her
homework oh well everyone you spoke to
is it maybe you might want to broaden
that circle out from her immediate
family and people she pays because if
you actually talked to anyone in the
democratic caucus who knows anything
they are all deeply unhappy with the
fact that AOC is constantly stepping all
over every serious legislative proposal
they put out but that's not even the key
here here is the key
Charlotte alter tweets this out she
tweets out AOC and I were born in the
same year remember she's a journalist
folks she's not the official
autobiographer she's not a ghostwriter
for a OC she's a journalist quote a OC
and I were born the same year she was a
dunkaroos kid I liked fruit roll-ups
people our age have never experienced
American prosperity in our adult lives
which is why so many Millennials are
embracing democratic socialism you have
got to be kidding me
people our age have never experienced
American prosperity in our adult lives
you spoiled child you spoiled brat and
aoc you spoiled child you spoiled brat
AOC writes yes and this is not just my
story this is true of wide swaths of our
entire generation who are now poised to
become a much more influential Civic and
electoral bloc as we mature into our 30
and beyond Wow Wow so it's so tough to
be a millennial well it's so brutal to
be a ma shut your head
honestly shut your head you don't know
the hell you're talking about you are
living the best life any people have
ever lived on planet Earth
you're living the country where you can
say anything you want you're living in a
place where you have more income than
anyone in history we're they touch of a
button any product anywhere on earth
will arrive at your door in three days
for the cheapest available price you are
living in a world where your chances of
starvation are zero or your chances of
homelessness are effectively zero if you
have any sort of social fabric or any
money at all in a world in which you
live in a nation with 3.8 percent
unemployment and 7 million unfilled jobs
where your poverty line involves having
a microwave a car a stove and a TV
you're whining about poverty you
Charlotte alter is whining about poverty
really okay Charlotte alter also tweeted
out in order to understand aoc you have
to look at what she experienced and what
she didn't Red Scare Reaganomics and
prosperous 90s were all before her time
her adulthood was defined by financial
crisis debt and climate change no wonder
she and her peers are moving left if you
think that living in the 2000s and the
2010s is brutal you're a doof you don't
know anything about history you don't
know anything about anyplace else on
planet Earth you're dumb you're ignorant
I mean like I don't mean to be insulting
but I do I'm sorry as you mean to be
insulting because these ideas are are
laughable
Charlotte alter complaining about the
difficulties of Millennials let me tell
you something out Charlotte alter okay
we're gonna talk about for a second who
this woman is who's claiming that as a
millennial you have never experienced
prosperity
Charlotte alter was born in 1990 1990
okay so that means that she is 129 years
old she's the same age as aoc her father
is Jonathan alter he's a columnist for
Newsweek and a correspondent for NBC
News he's one of the more famous
political commentators of the modern
world
her mother was Emily executive producer
on The Colbert Report on Comedy Central
her grandmother was the first woman
elected to public office in Cook County
Illinois
her uncle was the CEO of Sony she went
to Harvard University and then worked at
HBO and now has a show on Sirius XM oh
the suffering oh the humanity Charlotte
alter and her peers they've never
experienced prosperity ever it's just
incredible I mean what-what unbelievably
listen I know that there are some people
in America who are experiencing poverty
I know there are some people in America
who grew up in single-parent households
and really had to struggle to get ahead
I know there's some people in America
living in areas where the jobs have left
but they're nothing compared to
Charlotte alter I mean my goodness
imagine the difficulty of having to grow
up in a house where your mom produces
for comedy central and your dad is one
of the more famous columnist in the West
just imagine how rough that must be I
weep for her I weep for her it's always
astonishing to me to watch people who've
really had it pretty good in the United
States whine about how rough they have
in the United States like me I've had it
great in the United States I don't whine
about having it rough because I've had
it great okay and I grew up in a in a
two-bedroom house in Burbank California
that fits six people there's like an
1,100 square foot house it fits six
people it had one bathroom I slept in
the same bedroom as my three younger
sisters until I was 11 years old and you
know what my life was phenomenal I had
two parents who loved me I lived in a
neighborhood where all of us knew each
other there was a social fabric because
America is fricking great
America is terrific Millennials whining
about how rough they have it while
chomping down on avvocato toast is one
of the more obnoxious phenomena of our
of our modern world learn a thing a
thing in a second I'm going to show you
some charts to demonstrate that it's not
just Charlotte alters story that
Millennials have actually been pretty
well off that they stand on a 3,000 year
tradition of a West that has produced
prosperity science decency morality and
democracy and then they sit there and
whine about it all day and talk about
tearing it down in favor of a socialist
utopia that has never existed and will
never exist I'm going to show you the
stats that show that Charlotte alter is
not an outlier in terms of being
benefited from being in the United
States I have some charts and facts and
figures which mean more than Charlotte
Charlotte alters tweets about dunkaroo
by the way the fact that you I don't
even know why she's suggesting that she
was a dumpling like eating dunkaroos is
some sign of poverty when I was a kid
that's all I wanted
like dunkaroos I don't think we're
kosher and I was always looking at the
the commercials on TV oh my god those
look fantastic
my cookies that you dip into chocolate
dip and it comes in a package that's
amazing
in a second we'll get to all of that
first I want to mention that you should
go over and subscribe over at daily
wire.com $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription to daily wire comm $99 a
year gets you a subscription plus that's
an annual subscription it's cheaper plus
you get this the leftist tiers hot or
cold tumbler cast your eyes upon it it
is phenomenal as a thank you to our
daily water annual subscribers we would
like to give a shout out to a different
subscriber every Friday today
MERP add new tweet who dis we salute you
who you can see on this photo that MERP
has made three excellent choices first
he became a daily wire annual subscriber
that's how he got a leftist ears tumblr
second he bought my brand new
best-selling book the right side of
history number one on Amazon
number one nonfiction in Barnes & Noble
and finally he included those two things
in a photo with the hashtag leftist
tears tumblr MERP if that is your real
name thank you for being a subscriber we
really appreciate it now if you want a
chance at being featured on the show
become a daily where annual subscriber
if you're not already one post a photo
of your tumblr on Twitter or Instagram
you can even be in the photo if you
would like to become a subscriber go to
daily wire comm click on the subscribe
button at the top of the page and simply
subscribe you got all sorts of goodies
you get to ask me questions during the
additional two hours every day we do of
the show behind the paywall that you get
to access you can listen to it on talk
radio or you get a commercial free on
demand by subscribing over at daily
wire.com and listen to it at your desk
so go check it out right now also you
can ask us questions during the break
sometimes I think we're doing that today
we also are give you access to you asks
questions during the conversation you
just have all sorts of goodies you get
these Sunday specials on Saturday this
week we as dr. Steven Meyer who is a
philosopher of science talking about
intelligent design which is really
interesting stuff you get that on
Saturday go check all of this stuff out
over at daily wire.com
and make sure to subscribe at youtube
and itunes as well leave us a review we
always appreciate it we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
okay so it's time for me to share with
you some actual statistics not like AOC
I used to eat dunkaroos and live in an
upper-middle class area award a victim
am i okay we're going to talk about the
spread of products into American
households more generally is this is a
time line if you could see this why
should subscribe so you can see the this
is a time line of when products were
invented and how long it took for them
to be integrated into 100% of household
use in the United States so the
telephone the telephone took essentially
a full century from its invention until
it was available in a hundred percent of
households by 1970 it was available by
about eighty percent of households that
was you know seventy years between
invention and it's actual acceptance by
the vast majority of American households
if you look at electricity electricity
was made available at the beginning of
the 20th century it was not widely
available in all American household
until you got to about nineteen
forty-five nineteen fifty that's when it
was available in like eighty percent of
American households the radio was
invented in the mid 1920s and it was
available in most American households
and the vast majority anyway by 1940 now
look at the right side of this chart the
right hand side of this chart every
major invention of the modern era the
line from except from invention to
prevalence is essentially straight up
the smartphone was invented shortly
after 2000 by 2010 the smartphone was
available for more than 50% of the
public and by 2015 it was available to
75% of the public a 15 year lag period
between invention and acceptance by
everyone the digital camera was invented
in about 1995 it was already available
for pretty much everybody everyone had
won by ten years later so basically any
major product that has been invented
since 1970 in the United States has been
available to pretty much every American
household within 10 to 15 years and we
are whining about this we are
complaining about this in 1980 I have
statistics on consumption and wealth the
consumption per capita in 2015 dollars
in 1980 was nineteen thousand one
hundred eighty two dollars by 2015 it
was 38 thousand
one hundred and forty six dollars we had
doubled our rate of consumption it
doesn't sound like poverty to me the
share of household budget spent on food
clothing shelter and utilities went down
from 36 percent in 1980 to 27 percent in
2015 the share spent on entertainment
and recreation went from eight point
nine percent in 1980 to fourteen point
three percent in 2015 the average size
of a new home went from fifteen hundred
ninety five square feet in 1980 to 2,700
square feet in 2015 in other words guys
things have gotten a lot better and you
should stop your whining that's not true
for everyone listen if you're an
exception if you're somebody who's
really had it hard you grew up in
poverty obviously this is not true for
you but that's been true for all time
there are people growing up in poverty
AOC is not one of them to pretend the
millenials as a generation have it
significantly worse off than past
generations is to ignore the products
that we get to consume now the people
who are middle-class now live better
than rich people did even thirty years
ago the market capitalization of all
listed US firms inconsistent 2015
dollars three point four trillion
dollars in nineteen eighty twenty five
point one trillion dollars in 2015
life expectancy has risen by nearly six
years since 1980 the overall death rate
has dropped from one thousand seven one
hundred thousand people to 724 per 1000
people it has declined the death rate
for heart disease for cancer for
automobile deaths dramatically fraud
'mobile deaths for airline deaths is
gone from fifty three point nine per 100
billion miles flown to zero point two
working conditions we are working fewer
hours output per work hour has risen it
has essentially doubled in the United
States employee benefits have increased
mean retirement age has decreased
work-related deaths have been sliced in
had been sliced by four by a factor of
four and we're winding about this we are
complaining about this you've got to be
kidding me the money prices for consumer
goods move steadily upwards Americans
true cost of living is better measured
in hours and minutes of work and that
has been moving downward
consistently so money prices have gone
up that's because of inflation but when
you look at work our prices meaning how
much work it takes to buy a particular
product that has been declining steadily
since 1902 all-time lows now there is
falling real cost of everyday products
the iPad okay the the iPad when it was
introduced in 2010 and now when it and
now what it costs it only costs eighty
five percent of what it used to a movie
cost seventy four point six percent of
what it used to a pizza cost fifty nine
percent of what it used to cheaper
product better products and we are
complaining about this this is what is
causing socialism so the answer is it's
ingratitude that's causing socialism
it's not real conditions there's a lot
of people like ALC whining about their
wonderful upbringing in a fantastic
country show a little gratitude and
maybe you'll stop whining about the
system and start focusing on maybe the
fact that if you are not succeeding the
way you want to you need to change the
decisions that you are making you are in
control of your own life not some
important personal chaotic forces beyond
your control what we are watching right
now is a return to a misunderstanding of
civilization that's what we are watching
right now and talk about that in just a
second so what we are watching in
essence in the United States is a
misunderstanding of the system under
which we live we live in a free system
you get to make decisions that doesn't
mean we all start off in the same place
it doesn't mean we all face the same
obstacles we obviously do not we all
grow up with certain advantages in
certain disadvantage some of those are
much greater than others some of us grew
up incredibly wealthy some of us grew up
smarter some of us have more athletic
ability we all have different capacities
and we all we are all born into
different situations the question is do
we live in a country that is free for
you to make decisions and reap the
consequences of those decisions or is
the system quote-unquote rigged against
you and if it is quote-unquote rigged
against you is that because reality is
just reality or is it because there's
somebody who is actively standing in
your way what I mean by that is that
there are certain people who are just
going to do better than others in
American society people who are more
likely to make good decisions people who
may be smarter or faster or bigger or
taller or more beautiful that's been
true for all of human history and
government is not in a position to
rectify these cosmic and equi
the question is is government actively
impeding you from feeling the effect of
your own choices and if it is not then
maybe we ought to examine the choices
and discuss how we can make better
choices so that we succeed in American
society this is why I dislike populism
of both right and left populism
basically says two people will give you
what you want an excuse populism of the
right says well you know there are all
these factory towns where the jobs have
gone away and we've lied and we say it's
because of China and Mexico not because
of technological development and then we
say well we want to make sure that the
system isn't quote unquote rigged
against you and we're gonna have to show
me which part of the system was rigged
and why we wouldn't be better off just
saying to folks listen let's help you
make decisions if we're gonna help you
let's find private charitable ways to
help you make decisions that better your
life here's the true in a free country
the decision to better your life is up
to you and that's the country we live in
because that is the civilization that we
founded the civilization we found it was
based on certain fundamental principles
you are not at the mercy of forces
around you you're a free rational actor
made in the image of God so are all the
people around you you get to make those
decisions and you have a responsibility
to make good and moral decisions to make
virtuous decisions decisions that make
your life better and build the social
fabric this is what my entire book the
right side of history is about if we
reject those fundamental assumptions and
we assume that we are in fact just corks
bobbing about on the eddies of
civilization and that if we just
radically reshift it civilization then
suddenly it would be better for everyone
any attempt to radically reshift human
nature away from freedom and toward
oppressiveness from the top down in the
name of kind-hearted smiley-faced
redistribute of justice and social
justice all that's going to do is create
more misery which is typically what
these systems do in the long run can
meanwhile i think it is worthwhile
noting the democratic party has moved
dramatically anti-israel not only did
illa hana omar win johann omar the
anti-semite the representative for
minnesota not only did she somehow
amazingly get the Democratic Party to
fold to her but now the entire
Democratic Party is essentially
mirroring her position on the American
Israel Public Affairs Committee so AIPAC
is not a lobbying organization they do
not pay people okay they
they're a lobbying organization in the
sense that they bring consider they
bring Congress people to Israel and
educate them about the issues they do
not give direct donations to candidates
a pact is not a pact is largely
considered just a pro-israel place and
virtually every candidate right left and
center has spoken at APEC no matter
their position even if that position
happens to be an incredibly dovish
position on Israel Barack Obama needs to
speak there every year despite the fact
that Barack Obama was dramatically
anti-israel in policy because he wanted
to show listen my policy is not driven
by anti-israel animus now the Democrats
have decided they are not showing up
anymore
Ilhan Omar won how do we know she won
because she's retweeting people saying
she won because he'll head Omar started
this whole thing by saying it was Jew
money behind American support for Israel
and what she really meant was a pact
that's the Jew money and the Democrats
have decided ok I guess we'll go along
with that I guess we won't speak at
AIPAC anymore
now listen I have never been a big
advocate of AIPAC I think that they are
too left-wing I think they haven't taken
strong positions on things like the Iran
ziyal I've been highly critical at times
of AIPAC go back and look at the record
but for every Democrat to basically say
we're not speaking to a pro-israel group
because it would signal to our base that
we like Israel is pretty astonishing
Ilhan Omar won five count them five
Democratic candidates say they will not
attend the APEC policy conference this
year which is an astonishing move
considering again that all of these
people want to win Democratic primaries
and Jews vote overwhelmingly Democrat
Elizabeth Warren says no Kamala Harris
says no Bernie Sanders says no Julian
Castro says no South Bend mayor Pete but
a judge is also skipping apparently
Howard Shultz former Starbucks CEO is
not going moveon.org condemned AIPAC on
Wednesday in a series of tweets and so
they're all now they are all now
following the lead of moveon.org
of course AOC and Ohio Mar have been
leading the charge and it was a OS he's
chief of staff his chief of staff who
tweeted out today I hope it's not lost
on anyone this is a direct result of
Ilhan Omar's leadership Thank You Ilhan
Omar for showing such courage what was
her courage she said it was jus money
behind American support of Israel and
then she pointed her finger at AIPAC and
the entire left-wing media lip yeah
let's ask some questions about
Jews and their money the New York Times
ran a headline saying serious questions
to be asked about AIPAC and now we know
listen we know where the heart of the
Democratic Party is it is no longer with
Israel it is not a pro-israel party
anymore it is an anti-israel party the
fact that they won't even go speak even
to share their differences with AIPAC
demonstrates where they stand loudly and
proudly these are the fresh faces of the
Democratic Party
it's courage now it's courage by the way
apparently more Democrats have said that
they are not going to go now it's not
just 5 beta O'Rourke also says that he
is not going to show up either that
means that there are six Democratic
candidates who say they will not show up
at AIPAC because they're afraid of
ticking off the anti-israel and at least
partially anti-semitic base of the
Democratic Party that is pretty
astonishing meanwhile President Trump
yesterday recognize that the Golan
Heights were a part of Israel which is a
good move considering you don't want the
Golan Heights which is a strategically
important valuable asset in the hands of
Syria
it is literally a giant cliff to go on
Heights from which Syrian batteries were
shelling Israel in 1973 Israel had to
expend thousands of lives in order to
take the Golan Heights and keep them
safe for civilized people in Israel good
for the Trump administration yet we're
told the Trump administration is
anti-semitic but el hen Omar is not yeah
any more lies you want to sell their
press are a time for the mailbag so it's
a Friday that means that we are
obligated morally and logistically to do
some mailbag question so here we go
George says hi Ben as we all know the
New Zealand Prime Minister announced the
country would ban all semi-automatic
guns less than a week after the shooting
as a conservative I'm weary of
legislative changes being made in
reactionary fashion but I have
difficulties explaining why could you
maybe explain why reactionary
legislative action is bad or even maybe
why it isn't bad what are your thoughts
my general thoughts are that reactionary
legislation unless it is driven by a
pressing policy need that is backed by
evidence are bad why because emotional
responses are generally bad it is your
job as a human being to exercise your
reason not your knee-jerk emotional
response and it seems that in the
aftermath of tragedy very often what
people do is they say here's my
knee-jerk emotional response guy used to
gun get rid of all the guns and if you
don't agree with me it's cuz you're a
bad person because you don't care about
what just
we saw this with with Sandy Hook in the
aftermath of the Sandy Hook shooting
that was when Piers Morgan was doing
this every night and I said to him that
he was bullying people by suggesting
their moral inferiority if they didn't
agree with him on gun control which of
course was true and effectively ended
his career on television the fact is
that that too many people in positions
of legislative power reacts to events
with character assassination of people
who disagree with them on policy that is
not a recipe for good policymaking if
you have good evidentiary policy that
has been based on evidence then you
should be putting that forward in non
crisis scenarios and then if there's a
crisis and public attention is on the
issue then you put it forward again but
if the idea is that we are supposed to
react in non reasonable fashion to bad
stuff that happens because there's an
emotional appeal and we can use it as an
emotional Club that's bad policymaking
and worse morality Stephen says Haven
you have thoughts on president Trump's
executive order to protect free speech
on campus thanks and I love your show
well Stephen I'm glad you asked I do
have some thoughts on this so president
Trump's executive order I was
withholding judgment until I saw the
text of it the text of it is benign and
then the text of it basically just says
that it's an invite it's essentially
advisory it says to college campuses
unless you take proper procedures to
protect free speech we are going to
remove your research funding but it
doesn't go any further into specifics
that effectively means that it's up to
the Department of Education to determine
whether the First Amendment has been
violated in terms of removing public
funding from universities that engage in
anti-free speech activity I have a
feeling that it's not going to be
invoked very often but just as a sort of
advisory opinion I think it's a good
thing and every administration
Democratic and Republican should
reinforce that idea by the way it should
be uncontroversial Barack Obama himself
was was very it was very hard on
colleges that attempted to shut down
free speech I praised him for it at the
time Nicholas says hey Ben what is your
opinion of Rob Manfred as commissioner
of the MLB as it relates to the rule
changes pitch clock intentional walk etc
shouldn't should the National League
adopted d-8 rule so i've general I'm a
traditionalist when it comes to baseball
so I'm not generally in favor of the z8
role I think it changes the strategic
nature of the game I understand the
rationale which is to keep old players
from having to play the field and also
you don't lose a position in the batting
order and there's some there's some rule
changes I think that would be good
number one you should have to pitch to
more than one batter if you are a if you
are a relief pitcher because it is very
irritating to watch seven relief
pitchers be brought in to finish one
inning and just waste a lot of time
second of all absolutely there should be
a pitch clock and we should not only
should there be a pitch clock batters
should not be allowed to back out of the
box 1000 times Nomar Garciaparra style
and release their their gloves every
five seconds it's ridiculous as far as
the intentional walk that's a bad rule
change you should have to throw the
pitches for the intentional walk I've
seen ball games where somebody throws
away the ball on an intentional walk and
somebody scores from third base on it
that doesn't waste really a lot of time
in baseball there's some rule changes
that are just done the idea that we go
to extra innings and you put a runner on
second sort of like the football rule
that that first person who scores when
it's just dumb it's silly but as a
general rule listen baseball is one of
the healthier sports right now baseball
if you had to buy stock in sports right
now you buy stock in basketball and you
buy stock in baseball you'd sell on
football NOAA says hey bud you often
speak about the social fabric and
community institutions like churches
being there for those in need
if these avenues continue to decline how
can those in need get help good question
I'm not sure they can other than
government intervention ISM which is why
you're seeing an increasing demand for
government intervention ISM the
beautiful thing about being a government
interventionist is you intervene with
the government in the name of doing good
you crowd out private alternatives and
then you point to the fact that private
alternatives have been crowded out to
grow government even more that's what
the welfare system generally does it
reduces private giving because we have
less money to give yesterday it was
pretty fantastic it was poram which is
one of my favorite Jewish holidays it
really just is a time of joy I told the
story of it on yesterday's podcast so go
back and listen to it and things I like
and was just driving around my local
community which is heavily Orthodox it's
a very Jewish community and I'm seeing
parents walking around on the street
with their kids dressed up in costumes
I'm seeing them drop off gift baskets
michl off my note and everybody else's
house we ourselves are driving around my
car my kids and I are walking up two
front doors and dropping off gift
baskets and you receive you know twenty
twenty-five gift baskets just from
people in the community who you've had
over to your house and who have been
over to your house and you think
yourself this is what the social fabric
looks like you know if you have a social
fabric and you know if you don't and the
reason the social fabric exists
of course this is a pretty diverse group
of people diverse jobs diverse
experiences from a variety of countries
and yet we all have a common goal and
that is to worship God in Jewish fashion
and that is a good thing it builds
community I mean I turn I turn to my
wife last night and we were driving
around I said this kind of social fabric
is is really what built the West it's
this kind of social fabric that makes
America a terrific place de Tocqueville
talks about this and it's worthy of
emulation and strengthening daniel says
haben my 13 year old son Elliot is
listening to the podcast with me today
can you give them a quick shoutout done
Elliot subdued
let's see Beatrice says I think this
week you mentioned it was a Jewish fast
day and therefore you could not drink
out of the leftist tears tumbler that
got me thinking how do you include young
children in the celebration of Jewish
holidays although I am Christian I think
there's value in observing the Jewish
holidays with my family would love to
get your advice on this topic
thank you I'm listening from Spain
waiting for your new book to arrive well
Beatriz I really appreciate it thank you
so much for buying the book you know we
included the Jewish holidays are really
heavily geared toward kids Passover
particularly is very geared toward kids
famously the kids ask the four questions
is monotone aha Lila's dad that whole
thing the whole goal of that is to get
kids involved in the Seder so you give
them projects you give them assignments
every Saturday my kid every Shabbat my
kids have to tell us about the Bible
portion of the week and they learn about
it in school the kids are pretty
knowledgeable my daughter who's five
knows the entire story of Purim
and she can tell it back to you and she
finds it interesting and entertaining
Jewish holidays really so many
institutions in Judaism are geared
towards teaching of children it's a
wonderful wonderful thing and by the way
I think that Christians should know a
lot about Jewish holidays after all if
you're a Christian jesus was Jew you
should know about the holidays that
Jesus celebrated and in the Last Supper
was a pay cell was a Pesach dinner was a
Passover dinner
Paul says been congratulations on the
success of your new book can't wait to
read it what are your thoughts on the
group of Orthodox Jews who came out in
defense of Representative Omar I assume
you are talking about the natori Carta
they're a terrible group of people they
suggest that the State of Israel is a
moral abomination they've gone and met
with the dictators of Iran they are used
as a they are used as a front group for
anti-semitism by anti-semites all over
the world who hate Jews and find them a
convenient face they're sort of the
right-wing version of J Street it's a
front group that is designed in anti
Israel anti-jewish way or Jewish voices
for peace and then people who don't like
Israel can point to uh here are my Jews
these are these are the Jews I like over
here kate says hey been a huge fan of
yours my question is as a pro-life woman
and someone who is struggling with
fertility problems I'm curious about
your view on in vitro fertilization from
what I've gathered clinics automatically
destroy embryos that don't meet a
certain standard do you believe this is
a form of abortion and if so should this
be something we talk about as pro-life
conservatives in order to be consistent
in our views of life at conception thank
you so much so I don't know enough about
the destruction of embryos my view is
that if you destroy an embryo that is in
fact a form of abortion and that's why
you should only implant the number of
embryos that you are willing to give
birth to and that may be more expensive
but that seems to me the only pro-life
way to do it so I'm not against in vitro
in the sense that if you fertilize an
egg and then you implant it artificially
in a woman's uterus that that is is
something terrible I don't agree with
that but a destruction of an embryo
obviously does raise serious pro-life
moral concerns Jeffrey says hi Ben you
said we should not be prejudiced against
people who practice a religion does this
mean we shouldn't be prejudiced against
people who practice a religion that
holds very evil views and morals can you
see a religion that is not acceptable
and worthy of being prejudiced against
well a religion is a viewpoint what I
mean by you shouldn't be prejudiced
against a religion is that religious
practice alone should not disqualify you
from being seen as holding certain views
so I've said for example that wearing
hijab does not mean that you are a anti
Western or anti-american or anything
like that I I wear a funny hat every day
I think that your viewpoint can
obviously be held against you and it
depends on your viewpoint if you are a
radical Islamist that is a religious
viewpoint radical Islamism is very very
bad radical Islamism is not only
fundamentalist it is the anti woman and
it is in its anti Western so obviously
it can hold that viewpoint against
someone just as you would hold communism
or socialism against somebody
ideologically speaking what I mean is
that simple religious practice alone
cannot be these the barrier to being
seen as a fully fledged Westerner
obviously you should be able to worship
however you choose so long as your
ideology itself is not evil so again
religious practice generally is not
sufficient as a marker to to rule people
out of line in that way
Rachel says Ben
Thursday you talked about how it's
unfair to judge jordan Peterson on being
photographed with someone in a dumb
shirt so this also applied to Obama and
Farrakhan or is this different because
we know the views of Farrakhan thanks
and love the show well obviously I think
it's different because Farrakhan has
been a long time open anti-semite Jordan
Peterson didn't know this guy's guy
walked up wearing a shirt with a lot of
words on it
I assume that Jordan wasn't sitting
there scrutinizing his shirt so that's
that's a different thing
Louis Farrakhan is a very very famous
anti-semite who's met with pretty much
every Democratic member of Congress at
this point or at least a lot of them so
that is a very different thing
Alfredo says dear Ben you often talk
about the fresh faces of the Democratic
Party who in your opinion is the future
of the Republican Party is a run for any
type of office in your future from your
fellow commie for Nia and Alfredo a
couple of answers to this one so you
know I I obviously have praised nikki
Haley highly in the past I really like
nikki Haley I've you know I think a lot
of people around last time are quite
wonderful yeah I like Ted Cruz I like
senator Cruz I like senator Rubio I like
representative Dan Crenshaw I like Greg
Abbott the governor of Texas I like Ron
de santis the governor of Florida there
there they're a lot of really good
up-and-coming young Republicans who have
pretty solid records and I'm excited
about the future of conservatism among
among a lot of those faces as far as a
run for office in my future man you'd
have to make a convincing case I love my
job I have a great life I get to sit
here and be as purist as I want to be I
don't have to travel around leave my
family for weeks at a time I don't have
to fundraise you'd have to make a really
really strong affirmative case as to why
I should run Clement says hi Ben I'm
French and in love with us at Maine
values I understand them a lot more
since I follow you can you explain the
difference between the anglo-saxon
Enlightenment and the French one thanks
absolutely I have a book it is called
the right side of history and a large
part of that book is dedicated to the
difference between between the Scottish
English American enlightenment and the
French enlightenment the French
enlightenment saw the Enlightenment as a
break between reason and religion that
all the judeo-christian values of the
past could now be abandoned and we had
to build a new morality on the basis of
reason alone the cult of Reason was
actually an actual worshipped called in
France during the French Revolution like
they actually went into the the they
actually went into knows her Dom they
ripped out all the crosses and they put
up a staff
- of something that they called reason
and then they actually worshiped reason
this is not a joke that something that
actually happened during the French
Revolution it was called the cult of
reason and then there was the cult of
the supreme deity and that was founded
by Robespierre and now supposed to be
sort of the dias response to the cult of
reason but it effectively was the same
thing the fact is that when you withdraw
from the fundamental principles that
undergird Western civilization in the
name of reason you destroy reason itself
when America understood is that you need
a social fabric builds on
judeo-christian values and that you can
reason but you have to make the
fundamental assumptions of
judeo-christian values and then use
reason in accordance with those so the
fundamental premises themselves should
not be questioned meaning the the fact
that the universe is an orderly place
the fact that human beings are made in
the unique image of God and human beings
have creative power and freewill and
that history is a progression and that
you can impact the world and all of
these principles are stuff I talked
about in the right side of history the
French Revolution dispensed with them
in doing so they dispensed with
individual rights in favor of romantic
nationalism they they valued equality of
outcome rather than equality of rights
and they did an enormous amount of
damage so people I've heard the critique
that my book is anti enlightenment that
is such absolute sheer crap I can't even
believe it
I mean you have to be illiterate to
believe that I'm super Pro enlightenment
the goal of my book is to explain that
the Enlightenment had roots and didn't
magically spring into being in 1760 and
that we have to recognize those roots or
we lose the part of the Enlightenment
that is actually worth preserving
Matthew says hi Ben you got me hooked on
the Bible I can't thank you enough for
that you made me rethink my views I went
from being an atheist to devout
Christian that's fantastic
I've had the Bible read to me carefully
twice I'm amazed at how much I still
don't understand it took me seven hours
to read Deuteronomy chapters 1 and C
well then you're reading it correctly
I'm really frustrated with how difficult
it is to read the Hebrew and understand
it are there things that I just won't
understand unless I speak Hebrew and
read it in Hebrew what do you recommend
I do any help would be extremely
appreciated well if you want a pretty
good translation of the if you want a
pretty good translation of the Hebrew
there's a new Bible commentary that is
out by Rabbi solavei check that I that I
don't remember if I've recommended it
already this week I think that I have
it's it's a Bible commentary by Rabbi
Joseph Baer soloveitchik one of more
famous rabbis in the 20th century and
the translation of the Bible is quite
good and it has
commentary below it so that's a good way
to study it so you're not just trying to
read it straight speaking of which
there's another great book by rabbi Sol
of a trick called the logic man all
about why Jews follow Jewish law why
Jewish law matters even a world where
you think that you have natural law
principles really really worth reading
rabbis elevate check one of the great
thinkers in in modern Jewish history so
you can go pick up a copy of Habakkuk
man already um okay let's let's move to
a couple of things that I hate okay so a
couple of things Elizabeth Warren not
understanding things so senator
Elizabeth Warren she's running the the
progressive populist left-wing viewpoint
which is shocking because she started
her career as a moderate talking about
economic problems in the United States
the to income trap and all the rest of
this stuff she suggested she was a fan
of school vouchers for example now she's
abandoned all that and she claims that
she wants to break up Amazon but don't
worry guys we won't hurt anybody in any
way because if one person knows how to
run a business it's the lady who's never
done it somebody starts to grow a
business in there then Amazon Google
Facebook just reaches out and snatches
up the business and that's not that
doesn't promote competition so I think
they ought to be broken apart run that
platform you can still go online and
search for twenty eight coffee makers
that can be delivered in 24 hours but
break that up from the part about
running a business that competes on that
platform okay this isn't this is so dumb
it's so unspeakably stupid
so her suggestion is that you're gonna
be able to get the same things at the
same prices if you increase the cost of
production for Amazon she says that
Amazon shouldn't be able to be
vertically integrated in other words she
wants it said if you make coffee makers
you should not be able to distribute
those coffee makers this is true of
legitimately every business in the
United States that you're going to give
a competitive advantage to the products
that you make so the hell what that's
good for the market like if Amazon
produces a product and then they have
product services why would I not buy the
one that is cheapest and best the left
make the same argument about Microsoft
they're like oh you know it'd be great
let's break up Microsoft it's too big
and you know what happened the product
got worse and the price went up so in
elizabeth warren says yeah by breaking
them up and increasing their cost of
production i'm serving the consumer no
you're not
you're not serving the consumer you're
serving the interests of people who
would like to artificially raise the
cost of doing business to Amazon this is
the difference between consumer based
antitrust action and production based
antitrust action consumer based looks at
the consumer and says is the consumer
being jacked if not shut up production
costs production side antitrust says the
company is too big
why because I say so time to break it up
even if it's not hurting the consumer
that's a bunch of nonsense that's that's
what elizabeth warren engages in pretty
regularly okay other things that I hate
so bad
yeah dude rad so he has a bad habit of
jumping up onto countertops which was
both unsanitary and stupid it's like he
watched Dead Poets Society one too many
times he's like you know what'd be great
I'm just gonna find a countertop and
jump on it
it's what I do I eat new Mexican dirt
and I jump on countertops
bata skateboarding into your heart yeah
so here's baito explaining we don't need
any walls we don't need any walls in a
room filled with walls any walls thirty
billion dollars two thousand miles long
30 feet high it will not be built on the
international boundary line which is a
centerline of the Rio Grande River that
wall will be built well into the
interior on someone's ranch someone
else's farmed someone else's home you
and I will be forced to take their
property to solve a problem that we do
not have okay I'm so bored with Maido
O'Rourke at this point not only is his
point not well taken because if you are
to build any sort of barrier presumably
there will be land upon which the
barrier must be located and we should
always worry about the extent of
government overreach when it comes to
eminent domain something he by the way
do not worry very much about when he was
a city councilman in El Paso but bata
O'Rourke's sophomoric ramblings about
why walls are unnecessary generally the
fact this guy is considered a
front-runner to the Democratic Party
shows a certain lack of ideas now it
doesn't mean everybody on the Left lacks
ideas but the fact that this guy is
considered an idea guy like here's the
thing no one considered Trump and idea
guy like I can't name the number of
people like legitimately who think Wow
Trump there's a man with ideas there's
more like Trump there's a man who's a
giant pulsating middle finger to
everyone I dislike
that was the appeal of Trump forbade oh
it's like man he's a deep thinker
and he's like yeah brah I am a deep
thinker have you ever wondered why you
park on a driveway and drive on a
Parkway ever wondered that like really
thought about it I've ever spent any
time thinking about like why is it that
they put locks on 7-elevens if their own
if they're open for like 24 hours a day
what's the point of the lock yeah that
guy all right we'll be back here a
little bit later with two more hours of
wonderful goodness you can subscribe
right now and you can get that or we'll
see you here on Monday also make sure
that you pick up a copy of my
best-selling book the right side of
history number one on Amazon number one
in nonfiction at Barnes & Noble really
racing up the sales charts thank you so
much for supporting and I think it's an
important book I really I don't think
all of my books are equally important I
do not love all of my children equally
this is the book I love the most I think
it is the most important book I've ever
written so I appreciate you going out
and taking a look at it and we'll see
you here a little bit later i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam Tsai
Yvette's audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today with all of these very deep
ideological divides in our country are
we on the verge of a civil war what
would it look like if we were headed in
that direction what would a civil war
look like we'll try to talk about all
that today also how old is too old to be
President should there be a cap an age
limit on the presidency and finally what
does it mean to say that the Bible is
the the inspired Word of God that's what
Christians say but what does it mean
practically speaking we'll try to
analyze that today as well over on the
Matt Walsh show